there is so much uncertainty right now
and plenty of misinformation out there
so we're taking your questions straight
to our experts we're doing this every
night just we to see your questions - at
Fox News night
all right providing answers for us
tonight's foxnews contributors dr.
Nicole Sapphire and dr. Marty Meharry
thank you both for being up late with us
so early as is the case depending on
your time zone good to have you guys
with us thanks for having us all right
I'm gonna start with our first question
comes from T samples a few questions
that have probably been asked and
answered number one what's the
difference between kovat 19 and flu
since both are viral why is kovat 19
considered more dangerous than flu since
flu has killed many more people than
covin 19 doctor Ranieri at least to this
point
well what's concerning about covin 19
and that is a sister of a corona virus
which is the same thing that causes the
common cold it was involved in SARS
where as influenza is a separate virus
this has a rapid increase and that's
what we're concerned about is its rate
of spread we're seeing already in Italy
these cases come in at 90 deaths say
about 10 days ago in one day - 350
deaths on Saturday that's what we're
concerned about with kovat 19 yeah dr.
Safire anything you want to add there
about the differences you know a lot of
the panic comes from the unknown and
with the fluid is something that is dr.
Macario said you know it comes every
year although the strains vary we have
vaccines for we have known treatments
for it and although we know tens of
thousands of Americans die every year
you know we've come to expect it we
really do we really are able to prevent
a lot of that illness what the concern
that Kovach 19 is is that it's a rapid
uptick of cases right now as you see we
hear more and more cases every day by
the hour and it's whether or not our
health system can handle that rapid
amount of cases all at once yeah and dr.
sapphire that gets me to the next
question from Peter snug who says what
steps are being taken to increase the
number of beds available to care for
those who need to be hospitalized what
are the limiting factors to increasing
that number ASAP
well this is these are the million
dollar questions right now it's
something that we're dealing with and
looking at very closely and fortunately
there has been great movement from the
federal government in terms of trying to
get funding we have the bill that
although isn't passed thus far in the
Senate passed Congress as well as by
declaring the natural emergency and the
Stafford acts we're getting funding so
that we are able to mobilize support
there are a lot of hospital systems
already right now that are saying we're
gonna cancel all elective procedures
that way to keep beds free and keep
healthcare staff available we also have
some makeshift medical units being set
up some are being set up by the
government and some are being set up by
private institutions a lot of health
care hospitals and just small practices
are doing telemedicine and that's to
keep patients out of the hospital all of
these things together are just trying to
make sure that the hospital's can take
more patients we are still in the middle
of flu season so that hospitals tend to
be quite full so the goal is to just
keep the numbers down as much as
possible
yeah and doctor Meharry I was reading
today about how the military can get
involved certain things that they can do
and one of the things I was reading
about her that the mass hospitals for
those of us of a certain age who would
remember this show that was so wildly
popular I mean the ability the military
has to add to the beds into the system
by standing up there you know facilities
in emergency as well I mean is that you
know part of this equation and trying to
make sure we have enough beds absolutely
the military has its own health care
system it's deployed in in the
battlefield they have tents and they can
set up operating rooms if you look at
Wuhan they set up 19 field hospitals and
they were still overrun Mahan is a city
of 10 million people it's not into the
you know the entire population of China
so we need to do that we need to expand
I'm concerned that we're not going to be
able to do it fast enough and that's why
we talk about trying to reduce
transmission rates so we don't get the
surge at once it's a double whammy
healthcare workers are at highest risk
and could be out of commission and we
could see a mass influx which requires
more health care workers yeah and we
have all been looking at this story out
of the telegraph today which is talking
about this protocol document they say
they've seen in Italy where they're
making the
decisions about how they'll decide who
gets specific medical care and and the
talking about people who are over 80 and
have poor health and a scoring system
that they have for making these
decisions so that leads me to my next
question that comes in from Boris it
says once the system becomes overloaded
what criteria will be applied to triage
patient patients start with you doctor
mercury I mean like as a medical
provider I got to assume that's the
decision you don't want to have to make
well first of all if you need anything
done in a hospital that can wait
wait okay if it's not going to increase
any risk hospitals are often now asking
you just to put things off okay so no
cosmetic surgery for the next three or
four months we need to build capacity
and the way we're gonna do that is we're
gonna figure out who needs intensive
care who needs a respirator or who's
close to needing a respirator and those
are the people we're gonna really focus
on most of these cases are mild or have
no symptoms those patients should not
show up okay dr. sapphire this tweet
comes in to us from Tracy what is the
length of the illness is it 14 days is
it longer I mean we've heard about these
people who including people who say they
never really had bad symptoms but some
of the or quarantine from these cruise
ships and they keep testing positive but
they don't have a fever they're not
coughing I mean they're hitting like 40
days now so what should you expect with
being sick or Shannen it's a great
question and obviously things keep
changing as more data comes out so
that's far it does look like the
incubation period is about five days
meaning from when you're exposed to the
virus and the onset of symptoms which is
different than the flu because it's
shorter with the flu therefore you get
sicker sooner and you're isolating
yourself sooner which is why with kovat
19 we tend to be infecting more people
because it's tend to be asymptomatic or
just with mild symptoms a bit longer
once you develop symptoms at that point
it does seem like the symptoms stick
around much longer as well unlike the
flu flu only takes a couple of days you
feel pretty crummy with the flu but it
goes away in a few days with co19 it
seems that people have symptoms for a
lot longer sometimes up to 14 days now
people are testing are still testing
positive longer than that I just
I just mean that they're shedding the
virus it doesn't necessarily mean that
they're still actively contagious we're
still trying to figure out exactly what
all of this means some people shed
longer than others it's hard to say but
once you actually get symptoms you are
in a mandatory 14 day quarantine until
you have at least two negative tests 24
hours okay and this is a question we've
gotten a lot this one comes to us from /
osius i think is the spelling there what
is the current consensus or data on how
long it can last on surfaces there's a
wide disparity in reporting on the
number of days I've seen anywhere from
three hours to 28 days we need
clarification on this dr. Meharry well
it's two hours on copper or steel it
could be a little longer depending on
the amount of moisture and on fabrics or
plastic it could be days so people need
to be need to be mindful that surfaces
are one of the most common modes of
transmission especially our phones so
when you wash your hands got you got to
remember that phone is an extension of
your hands it's true we set those things
down anywhere he had an important thing
to point out a lot of people got
confused because last week a study came
out that was that they tested they
essentially sprayed a mist of the virus
and then they they recorded whether or
not they can still identify virus
particles there and they said that
particles were on steel and plastic for
three days and a cardboard box for one
day and just lingering in the air for
three hours after the person wet it's
important to remember that that is just
a study that is not actually real life
and just because that they can still
find the particles there it doesn't
necessarily mean that they're viable
enough to cause an end detection system
the bottom but the bottom line is the
most common way that you're gonna get
this is if you're near someone who's
asymptomatic who's coughing and sneezing
and so as dr. Meharry said what you want
to do is especially right now we're
we're we're socially distancing you see
we're at home in our home studios can
you clean everything down constantly
wash your hands constantly don't touch
your face you know all common-sense
measures that everyone at home can do we
got to stick with it all right dr.
sapphire dr. Meharry thank you both for
your time we appreciate it